welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition in this episode
we'll be breaking down the stranger on
Netflix the show has a lot to unpack
from it and throughout this video we'll
be going through its overall plot and
the ending there will be heavy spoilers
here so if you haven't had a chance to
watch the series yet and don't want to
know what happens then I highly suggest
that you turn off now well the way I
just want to give a huge thank you for
clicking the video now let's get into
our breakdown of the stranger did you
see Corinne this isn't what you think
there's more to this the stranger is
based on the 2015 book of the same name
by Harlan Coben initially the series
opens on Adam Pryce a football dad who's
approached by the titular stranger and
with there comes an allegation about the
characters wife Corinth
early in their relationship Adam was
going to break up with Corrin but he
stayed with her because she was pregnant
however the stranger reveals that this
was faked along with the miscarriage
that followed not long after it sets
alarm bells ringing in his head and she
carries a warning that he may not even
be the father of his two sons Adam sets
out to know the truth and it slowly
tears his marriage apart and plants
paranoia and distrust in the couple
whoever Koren says there is more to the
story than meets the eye
and after she disappears it sets Adam
off on a quest to get to the bottom of
it all it's a brilliant way to open the
show and it sets up the aesthetic that
the stranger has the ability to tear
people's lives in two similar to the
source material this enigmatic figure
seems to know at all she's like a ghost
because the stranger begins to torture
everyone that she comes into contact
with blackmailing them and revealing
hidden secrets that she somehow acquired
there were links together
and though there are several strands to
the storyline that seem unconnected they
all interweave with one another making
for a gripping narrative I'm going to be
breaking down the show in non
chronological order just to simplify
everything as it gets complex with
certain reveals the main players are the
aforementioned
Chindi Adam and Corrin Adams client
Martin - detectives Joanna and Wes
Joanna's friend Heidi and a group of
high-school people's Joe though don't
let her hear me call her that finds her
decapitated alpaca which is linked to a
boy named Dante that overdosed in the
woods Dante is a youtuber with 3,000
subscribers and I did warn him that
something bad would happen if he didn't
stay off my patch he secretly filmed
Karim before she went missing and these
are sort of voya
we learned that apparently Koren stole
money from the school football club and
this becomes a big plot point in the
finale I'm jamming ahead here but it's
revealed that one of the high school
students was suspected of sending child
pornography to the entire school the
victim's sister believed this to be a
boy named Mike Tripp and now she spiked
him with PCP and during this trip excuse
the pun he decapitated the alpaca Mike
believes he may be responsible for
Dante's condition but we discover it
with someone else which I'll get into
later
Heidi is blackmailed by the stranger and
is told that if she doesn't pay up her
daughters only fan account or whatever
it is will be put online but I don't
know what it's called
just in case my wife's watching don't
look out our bank statements this puts
our on a path with a dangerous policeman
named detective John Katz who will do
anything to cover up a secret he murders
Heidi and this came to me as a huge
surprise especially if he'd been keeping
up-to-date with how the show has been
promoted Jennifer Saunders was doing the
chat show circuit earlier this month and
I see her taken out by a crooked cop was
a huge turn up for the books it's
revealed that John is working for a rich
businessman who met with Heidi's
daughter several times and became her
sugar daddy John has been tasked with
covering this up hence his hunt for the
stranger speaking of policemen through a
retired one named Martin Adam is helping
to retain his home against his father
Adams father used to live in the area
and the two actually have a
long-standing grudge with one another
that's revealed later in the show with
the help of Martin he tracks Koren
through a woman named Susan who was also
blackmailed by the mysterious figure at
the center of it all what's so great
about the stranger is that most of it
seems grounded implausible other than
John and a character I'll get into in
just a bit
nothing is really over the top there's
not many twists that don't
seemed like they couldn't happen we
exist in a world where we freely hand
over private information on our lives to
social media and you can see how someone
could easily build a database of
blackmail material on a target there's
also a theme of what you don't know
can't hurt you
that I found arguably the most
compelling aspect of the show
the stranger pretty much forces the
information upon people at times and
some would rather not know
it's the classic notion that ignorant is
bliss and I found myself putting myself
in the characters shoes and wondering if
I'd want to know the truth if it would
destroy all that I'd built information
is power and this show it definately
exemplifies that it made me question if
the stranger was even the bad guy in all
this and whilst I did conclude that she
was a lot of the time she was only
punishing people who deserved it she was
catching a lot of people in a lie
however I think in the case of Heidi
that she did go too far and was simply
blackmailing her for the sake of it now
from here Adam tracks is stranger by
using the memory of an autistic man
named Max it's the usual trope where
autism is a superpower but it helps to
keep the plot moving this is the
character that was talking about before
and I always kind of feel like when they
do this in a show or film it is quite
lazy and and here I felt kind of like a
dead plot point luckily they don't dwell
on it too long and the cat and mouse
game with his wife also unearths his own
affair with an old work colleague now
everything in the show operates in
shades of grey rather than black and
white and Adam becomes a suspect in his
wife's disappearance her key fob was
planted at the crime scene of Heidi's
murder and John oversees the police
interview trying to find out what's
going on it's revealed that Jon has an
extremely sick daughter named Olivia and
her mother has Munchausen by proxy and
has been poisoning her it's really
messed up and the high school group
uncovered after trying to confront the
family over why Olivia told people Mike
was behind the spreading of the explicit
images that we talked about earlier it's
revealed that Olivia actually did it and
though Mike was spiked he wasn't
complicit in the crime against Dante
it's revealed that Daisy took his
clothes and the max came across Dante
and chased him his collapse turns out to
be an accident and max just ended up
leaving him it was probably the most
disappointing reveal on the show for me
as I was a
spectin big repercussions from this but
by the end it all just kind of fell flat
and got swept under the rug as for
Martin after his house is signed up for
demolition it's revealed that he
murdered his wife and hid her body in
his home and this is why he didn't want
to sell it like many characters he's
been living a lie for yes however unlike
the rest because he kept it in his home
no one was able to use the information
against him
everyone is skeletons in their closets
things that they hide and all that the
stranger is doing is pulling these to
the surface it's revealed that Martin
and the stranger have a connection with
one another and there's some irony in
the fact that she owned its secrets
whilst he hid them it makes for a really
gripping drama and as someone who was a
bit Maire from the first trailer I found
it really pulling me in there's just
something distinctively British about
the whole series and it manages to take
the mundane and elevate it so that
you're hanging off every scene and
performance that's no easy feat but the
cast do a great job of portraying real
people stuck in the myths of their lives
falling apart and it makes for brilliant
viewing slowly we learn about the
stranger and how she operates she states
early on in the season that her mother
ended up with the wrong man and this is
what's driven her it's why she exposes
so many affairs betrayals and things
from people's past and through her
accomplice Ingrid they're able to dig up
dirt on people and use the information
to blackmail them she pretty much has
been keeping tabs on the majority of the
characters in the show
deep down she thinks she has high morals
but really she's just a thief the
stranger is actually revealed to be
Bones child and this explains her keen
detective skills it also explains her
motives as after her mother apparently
left she became distrustful of Martin
and suspecting the lies Sheehan covered
the truth about how he killed her mother
the stranger learned that she wasn't
actually Martin's daughter when she
discovered they were incompatible for an
operation and she actually turns out to
be Adams half-sister due to Adams father
having an affair with the strangest
mother after the murder of Heidi the two
go into lockdown and try and get rid of
all the evidence
Adam ends up working with his father to
find his wife and they realized that the
stranger has been in contact with both
of them
John uncovers the truth about Olivia's
illness and we find out that Koren
suspected the poisoning to his
connection to Heidi's death as an earth
and this sends him against his former
co-workers after Adam is staking the
contacts him instead of Joe they collide
with the stranger and a partner John is
finally caught and arrested and it's
here that the truth about the strangest
kinship is revealed it's a huge twist in
the season that shows how tied together
all of the events are she told Adam
about Koren because they were family and
it's revealed that she was hired by a
co-worker of Koren to expose the truth
it turns out that she was actually set
up by Mike's dad trip so that he could
get away with stealing the money Koren
knew he did this and thought that the
pregnancy exposure was carried out by
trip and this is why she fled
unlike the stranger Koren kept the
secret but ultimately trips Bureau
exposure
pushed him over the edge and he murdered
her trip takes out him out to where he
buried Curran and it's a brutal last
half hour for the season I really didn't
see this turn coming and trip actually
almost talks the character out of going
to the police due to how the entire
setup and story of the season looks Adam
completely loses it and kills trip only
to be farmed by Joe she helps to frame
John who is already going down for a
crime and as it's his gun it's easy to
tie him to it the season closes with
Adam being cleared for the murder and
the characters all standing around
watching the football on the surface
they all look happy but there's an
undercurrent that they have once more
being trapped in a lie the stranger
watches over them and her father we
wonder if it's all going to blow open
once more with even worse consequences
the ending signifies that lies no matter
what almost always affect people and
lead to something negative the entire
story of how the show started off was
because of a secret being kept and due
to this everything snowballed out of
control once the lie was uncovered it
led to more and more being on earth and
yeah this pretty much tore everyone's
lives apart it completely wrecked the
families in the show and pretty much
every character who ends up dead or
damaged by the seasons clothes ended up
like this because at one point they
light this theme throughout the season
paints out the idea that the light at
the end will come to the surface
eventually John will have caused
protesters in a sense and even Joe seems
unsure if he'll be convicted as we know
he was in custody during trips murder
and forensics will likely be able to
verify this similar to Koren Adam is now
living on borrowed time purely because
the lie will eventually be brought to
the surface in one way or another and
this will also bring out the entire
conspiracy which seems to be hidden
Adams father never got his comeuppance
and now I don't think that the stranger
will expose Adam she will likely still
go after her dad this could bring
everything up and personally I really
took the ending as them acknowledging
that lies never have a positive outcome
even when we think they will Joe helped
Adam and though it seemed like a heart
was in the right place when discovered
he will go to jail as will she it's a
bittersweet ending and personally I
thought it was a brilliant way to end
the show I really enjoyed the stranger
and it's tight storytelling provided a
compelling watch throughout I did feel a
bit that the high school students
storyline didn't really go anywhere
especially the alpaca bit and it would
have been nice to have seen Mike's
reaction to his father's murder we also
never really find out if Adam is truly
the father and there's a lot of things
left up in the air I'm unsure if we will
get a second season at the moment so I
think niece would have brought a lot of
closure to the entire show saying all
that though I had tons of fun with it
and definitely recommend that you check
it out this weekend
the stranger was great and it gets an
8.5 out of 10
now obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on the stranger and what you
took from the ending comment below and
let me know and if you enjoyed this
video then please give it a thumbs up
and make sure you check out a breakdown
of last week's big Netflix release
chilling Adventures of Sabrina part 3
which is gonna be linked at the end we
go over the show and give our thoughts
on the ending so it's definitely worth
checking out if you want to know more if
you want to support the channel from its
little there's 99 cents a month then
please click the join button below you
get access to content early and can also
suggest video topics and breakdowns we
massively appreciate it and it goes a
long way to helping videos like this get
made every month we give away free
movies to people who are subscribed to
the channel and this month you can win
dr. sleep and all you have to do is
comment on a video and make sure you sub
with notifications on the more videos
you comment on the more you have a
chance of winning so make sure you get
involved the winners gonna be chosen at
random on the 15th of February it's the
best of luck that everyone who takes
part
this is the channel for people who are
never missing television so if that's
the kind of thing you like you need to
subscribe to definition thanks again for
taking the time to watch this you've
been the best and I'll see you next time
take care peace
you